hello there it's been four long long
weeks since we last met up for a map
update video and what a time to return
epic games are back from their summer
break season four is next month and the
narrative of the story is starting to
pick up again i'm adam maru here is my
code if you'd be so kind let's look at
everything new on the island in chapter
3 season 3 week 11.
so dragon ball super is now a part of
fortnite law over the next 14 days we'll
be facing a quest to collect all seven
dragon balls to summon shenron which
will then give us our very own free
glider pretty cool on the island a new
poi can be found over in the sanctuary
cove the kame house is waiting for you
to visit while we're all using these new
mythics we should probably remember the
law behind the seven dragon balls
especially if you don't watch the show
those who collect all seven are given a
wish from this legendary beast there's
been many uses in the show like bringing
back fallen heroes but the first time we
saw the earth's dragon balls used in the
show was to wish for this
the world's most comfortable pair of
ultrasound
super comfy underwear wow if epic chose
to this could be a great way to start
next season someone could collect all
those dragon balls and wish for control
over the zero point maybe there's
somebody already watching us right now
the dragon ball appearance has summoned
another relic to the island which means
story missions are finally back already
this season we've had a face-off with
darth vader before discovering a sith
holocron to gift him we've stolen an
ancient relic from the tomb whilst
running away from boulders and we've
seen the emblem of the ice king each
relic seems to be linked to power we
know little about this week the
scientists shed more light on this
situation amy and i have been at synapse
stations studying this relic situation
the zero point is definitely probably
intentionally summoning these relics but
we're not sure why
fortunately or unfortunately another
relic has just made landfall on the
island
maybe this one speaks zero point the
scientist believes the relics are being
brought to the island by the zero point
it's attempting to talk to us he
surmises the zero point is gifting us
these new powerful artifacts to prepare
us for a new battle we think that person
is the bloom watcher controlling the
reality tree as it spreads across our
flat world this week's relic is a simple
chair most people don't have a clue what
this is from but map change nerds like
you and i we know all about it this
magical chair has been around for a few
chapters back on the very first island
in the desert biome one chair became 100
chairs
it was a very strange scenario
those chairs somehow found their way
onto the second island on the back of a
flatbed truck then in chapter two the
same chair showed us a new ability it
could resize whenever it chose to while
the war between io the seven and the
cube fanatics rod on this chair and
whatever sat near it would change in
size each week it became one step
smaller and then suddenly it became so
small it was invisible to the naked eye
but it was still there we could zoom in
on it and that chair was still there
then weeks later it resets and became
standard size again then the island was
flipped and we thought we'd never see it
again back in game right now the chair
is protected by a force field luckily we
are able to break it and now the
scientist has it in his possession so
let's break down the relics the zero
point has given us so far first the
relics inside the rave cave which bring
us new world biomes then we found the
ice king shield a god who could control
well ice then a sith holocron to learn
about the power of the dark side then
the artifact that ascends mortals to the
level of gods and now we have a chair
with the ability to resize itself hey if
that means we're going to get a
shrinking rain fortnite i will lose my
mind while all this is going on
something very worrying needs to be kept
in mind the zero point continues to
plume with energy each time we grab a
relic that bot of energy is now so
strong it can be seen from light years
there it away again another zero point
energy shock wave magnitude 7.2 the zero
point has got to be bringing these
relics here because it wants us to have
them right
that was magnitude 8.5 shockwave
detectable from light years away and do
you remember what happened the last time
the zero point was felt from across
galaxies my huge devourer of worlds came
out for lunch and tony stark had to save
us all man that live event was fantastic
[Music]
so who is the big bad guy of this season
it seems to be the tree after the zero
point was freed from isle control a tree
was able to bloom from where its roots
stayed connected to the nexus other
routes have shaped our island all season
from logjam to this week and the end of
the daily bugle now it's a former poi
from chapter one lazy lagoon the home of
pirates and still the home of an undead
captain right now high up surging with
energy is the old daily bugle signage so
maybe it will return one day if we get
control over that tree what's for
certain is the grip the bloom watchers
reality tree has over us and yet again
it gets worse the roots have now spread
all the way to spawn island the place we
start every game will be changing in the
next update i personally hope it becomes
the original island from season zero but
more likely it will be keeping in with
other bloomed pois that was my favorite
campervan
one place the roots haven't reached yet
is tilted towers after the war efforts
last season it was a wreck well not
anymore a month of building and the new
and improved tilted towers has three new
buildings made by players of the game
pizza pit is replaced by this bistro the
apartment building has also had a huge
rebuild and the office block too we've
been told this constant upgrading of
tilted will continue each season as no
sweat insurance gladly takes all our
gold to remake the same buildings over
and over again the other project from
the underwriter and the no sweat
insurance crew this summer was
sponsoring the summer update and that
has all gone now which sadly means the
skate park floating on water we were all
looking forward to was here for
absolutely nothing at all
r.i.p skateboard update but wait there's
more secrets to go through this week you
may remember the foundation vanished
from the island a few weeks back we
assumed this was to keep the narrative
clear as he was chasing geno in another
dimension well that's not the case
members of the seven are currently going
missing all over the map right now one
of the seven centuries are patrolling
that spot and talking to them we are
told paradigm doesn't want us to discuss
disappearances wow okay two things to
break down here first the sentries now
have a name sven for the man svenja for
the woman i don't know their pronouns so
please don't get butthurt by me
presuming their gender the second part
of this issue will change everything the
foundation is officially missing next
week we'll be sent out to figure out
what the seven are doing and each one of
them has gone missing the foundation the
visitor and both of the sisters have
gone all leaving behind an item they
would need in the field leading us to
believe they've been abducted as we
approach the end of the season we'll
need to figure out who kidnapped our
favorite members of the seven and does
it have anything to do with the bloom
watcher or geno because thinking about
it it would be pretty simple to replace
one of the seven with an evil snapshot
if you have a theory on that please
throw it in the comments below
[Music]
at this point i hope to show you updates
to the rock family but no there's
nothing new here i also sat by
truckasaurus for four weeks hoping for
an update but nope still the same one
thing that has changed was the story of
lil whip over the summer he's let slip
that he's paying off a debt and to do so
he's selling ice cream all over the
island he honestly looks a bit in fear
and this week something bad has happened
a non-descript ice cream truck has been
left crushed by the side of the road it
may not belong to little whip his van
did look very different over summer if
you see him on your travels please talk
to him we need to know what's going on
also this is the second ice cream truck
that's crashed on the map another one is
in the north crashed by pili last season
one crushed ice cream truck is nothing
but two seems like too much of a
coincidence right oh i'm going to start
work on the zero war issue 3 breakdown
thank you very much for watching here's
a bunch of people who used my code over
the last month thank you so much for
doing that i'll be back in my twitter
dms tonight to thank you all personally
i'm adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure see ya
[Music]